mais elle va arriver taklha calmes c'est
bon et les chics et ça va arriver tout
de suite aussi ça prend une petite
seconde
le raid il va partir l'acama les parties
leur ai dit pars avec et l'échiquier il
va venir alors je vais faut que je chope
le premier en combien bombe au final
c'était sympa c'est juste un peu longuet
à la fin parce qu'on devait rester
jusqu'au bout parce qu'on devait stream
le truc dallas ont neuf et qu'on est
allé jouer notre jeu c'était cool
alors est ce que c'est bon ça a l'air
non est-ce que par avait passé alors
fait voir non elle n'est pas passée 1
je n'arrive pas trop à voir les noms en
bas alors je mens grand écran ni
al-sharif ainsi part à mes passes mais
quand il est passé par al anon parham a
fini 8e à élancée juste donc pas ramer
passé nepomniachi contre aucun pour le
mans ils font que de la mer sur le truc
en bas mais en gros happy feet and
rivers a ils ont mis des faux noms quoi
fasse beau là ils ont pas encore mis les
noms des joueurs ouais ça le sucre avant
fait
mais pour aller détruire est possible à
temps et les alertes c'est pas les
bonnes on va les enlever mon cela sera
réglé
miss beauté noire ce qui a fait le
design on va voir et la règle je sais
pas je pensais d'eux des matches aller
retour
alors en revanche et dans 30 minutes les
playoffs donc pendant 20 minutes
maintenant j'ai envie de te dire un
cariste et p6 avait des années que je
n'aime pas ce mouvement les et victoire
douteuse
pourquoi ils font rien d'après toi
allégeance à rien et coûte je sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas j'ai du mal à
comprendre
après là aujourd'hui ça allait quand
même plutôt pas mal je pense mais de
toute façon en vrai si on se parle
franchement les mecs n'importe qui de
sega qui est grand maître peut céder
extérieurement et personne ne remarquera
j'avais dans tous les cas tu pourras
jamais savoir en vrai je peux tu peux
jamais savoir donc vu que c'est
invérifiable en fait tu sauras jamais tu
seras jamais cessé impossible de savoir
on en discute avec fabc fab demain il
veut gagner le tournoi il le gagne enfin
il ya aucun problème mais toi tu sens
que le temps est naturel banon banon
expliqué un joueur sur 1000 et ça pose
tout le tournoi donc non non non dans
tous les cas moi mon tournoi exultant
avec j'ai joué - où il était naturel moi
n'y a pas eu de rupture mais partie mais
dans tous les cas en fait
c'est même que les joueurs sinon j'ai
trop justement le truc qui était pas en
fait vu gars je crois que le gave du
gars qui jouaient sur pièces comme il
s'est fait virer du truc de chartres je
crois que c'est la même personne donc
déjà les arénas c'est même pas sûr que
les gars quand il avait la camsa gruger
pas pour certains mais j'y crois pas fa
c'est plus difficile après quand les
gens commandent pas et allume juste leur
came l'échiquier c'est possible quand tu
commentes en même temps genre un gars
comme icare ou hypothèses
eric en scène tous les gens qui
commentent et qui joue dans c'est
impossible vraiment pas ce que tu peux
pas faire quarante mille choses à la
fois un moment donné c'est impossible
donc ouais les arénas king en vrai
c'était c'était le meilleur truc en soi
et donc ouais non non les gens qui les
gens qui stream les trucs streamer les
trucs où il ya des invités aussi à mon
avis tu vois les speech est en tout cas
le speech est adulte j'ai jamais eu
j'ai jamais eu le moindre doute de quoi
que ce soit à quoi mais la caméra qui
filme le voir juste filmer ça sert à
rien
bah c'est pas de chasse comme zhaojun
qui organise le tournoi l'a pas
l'intérêt de bruges et c'est que tu peux
gagner 5000 $ à la fin du tournoi après
là honnêtement c'est pas des joueurs là
des joueurs que je revois en premier
franchement c'est assez sa mère d'être
assez propre tu vois enfin mialy sarine
je le vois pas à gruger n'est pas je
vois pas griller vie de large doit pas
griller vont lui c'est le gros point
d'interrogation porte nick je pense pas
je pense qu'ils stream doubow je le vois
pas faire non plus artémias je vois pas
faire non plus par anne je le vois pas
faire non plus sur le tapis que vous
avez en bas donc non ça m'a l'air assez
bien
après après je sais pas après tu peux
jamais savoir et c'est ça le problème
les maxima jouer vrai
après tu sais pas donc et tu pourras
jamais savoir
ouais tu peux tu peux jamais savoir
c'est possible de faire un gros tout
regardez moi j'ai failli gagner de title
tu faisais quand j'avais fait nul contre
magnus est la seule pas faim en fait
s'ils avaient retourné le résultat parce
que j'avais perdu contre un tricheur
dans le truc mais tu as comme si tu as
joué contre un tricheur il fredonne pas
le point après donc moi en fait j'ai
fait au final tout à coup j'ai battu
magnus j'ai fait c'est sûr on ce parti
j'ai fini avec deux défaites une en
effet pour magna fait huit et demi sur
11 mai normalement le gars qui a grugé
contre moi j'aurais dû enfin normalement
tu dois me donner forfait à la fin du
tournoi et victoire le fait n'a fait une
mission sur les gagner le tournoi mais
ils rendent pas les points après donc en
vrai en fait même mois le seul tournoi
j'ai vraiment bien joué le truc et où
j'ai cartonné où j'ai fait le tour on a
de ma vie j'ai pas fait de prix et je
n'ai pas gagné parce qu'il ya un mec qui
gruge et sur le chemin
donc c'est un peu frustrant quoi quand
tu joues alors du coup quand tu es très
fort comme dépôt comme suit les airs
comme com diary sarine comme du golfe ou
quoi comme des tournants à ce niveau là
tu veux en faire sur douze suivants
faire quatre ou cinq au niveau que
j'avais toujours là ça va mais pour un
gars comme moi qui peux faire une telle
perf une fois tous les dix ans en fait
la folle et disant je vais le faire je
vais me faire brûler parce qu'un mec
aura gruger donc cas c'est très
démotivant quand même en soi mais ça
veut pas dire que quand tu es très fort
tu peux pas y arriver quand même mais je
l'air pur des gens moins fort en fait
c'est c'est vraiment dur
les sanctions prévues si tp show et même
pas vraiment en fait juste titre fait
sortir du tournoi et tu peux plus
rejouer pour un prix pendant un certain
moment
ouais c'est possible que le maître fide
soit dans mon cas la probabilité de 1%
mais il ya un pour cent de chances
qu'ils soient les gîtes peut-être tu
vois où 2% ou 3% je sais pas mais le
problème c'est que tu peux pa bann
quelqu'un s'il ya un pour cent de
chances qu'il soit ils soient ok c'est
tout même c'est une chance sur dix mille
tu peux pas le ban donc pas ok il doit
jouer tu peux pas on est bien d'accord
donc c'est pour ça qu'en fait de facto
je comprends pas l'intérêt du tournoi en
soit en fait
c'est ça le truc c'est donc et donc du
coup en fait c'est pour ça que je pense
que des gens comme icare ou quoi ils
sont liés at il été aussi dans ces
tournois là parce que ben ouais c'est
juste un essai le problème c'est le
problème du truc en fait c'est le
problème profond du truc mais je pense
que l'attitude de jazz comme par rapport
à ça les normales je veux dire par là
que de ne pas bannir sans être sûr à
100% je trouve que c'est plutôt bien de
la part de chess comme parce que sinon
tu te retrouves avec des gens qui ont
rien fait qui se font bannir et ça c'est
pas normal et je trouve que c'est pire
pour moi c'est encore pire quand tu
banny quelqu'un qui a rien fait parce
que tu lui mets une étiquette de
tricheurs sur la gueule alors que t'es
pas sûr à 100% donc je suis 100%
d'accord avec le je suis complètement
d'accord avec l'attitude de jazz comme
de bagnères que lorsqu'ils sont sur deux
sur ça je trouve que c'est bien
en revanche le problème c'est que du
coup bas dans ces cas-là ça laisse la
porte ouverte un peu à tout il laisse le
bénéfice du doute et ça je trouve que
c'est plutôt bien et ça c'est plutôt
bien
c'est tant mieux ça disons ils ont
raison parce que sinon tu te retrouves
avec des cas où vous savagnier à gauche
à droite et une fois sur cinq ans tu
trompes et tu fais du mal aux gens et à
passer comme ça tu peux pas je peux pas
accuser des gens comme ça les diarrhées
parce que t'es pas ce que tu penses que
et comment on est sûr à 100% c'est ça le
problème en jeu botte c'est très très
rare et souvent dans les trucs qui
peuvent être dit que je sais qu'ils
peuvent être dit souvent ils en sont
sûrs 1 200 % quand il ya deux tricheurs
qui s'affrontent
parce que là du coup ça fait des parties
d'ordi mais le problème c'est que les
gars maintenant qu'ils le font ils sont
de plus en plus malin et joue ajouteront
accoudoirs dit dans la partie et ça
suffit pour une fois de temps en temps
gagné le tournoi
ouais j'suis d'agglo qui est le mieux
dit coupable d'orcanie noz en privons tu
te présentes suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça
c'est le problème ouais sur liccia sa
détection et meilleurs alors je sais pas
comment c'est maintenant mais avant à 99
pour cent i bat nice est sûre et chasse
comme ils bannissent que à 100% quasi
100% avant c'était ça la différence
maintenant je connais je sais pas
comment c'est aujourd'hui
avant c'était ça la différence mais
après les politiques anti cheat et tout
ça elle évolue
le truc c'est qu'il faut pas péter de
plomb de moi quand je joue sur internet
et que je 803 +0 comme n'y a pas
d'argent en jeu et que c'est pas
détourné avec temps chaîne les parties
ça me fait pas du tout tilt là je pense
que les derniers jours à une
recrudescence de maquis gruger contre
moi juste impression là mais ça ne fait
pas tilt du tout pourquoi parce que en
fait je peux zapper l'adversaire et
faire des matchs intéressants contre
d'autres personnes donc bon ok tu as
perdu une partie et puis face on joue
pendant cinq six heures d'affilée
si pendant cinq six heures la plupart du
temps j'en ai 0 même si j'ai deux gars
qui gruge sur six heures pas grave
pas grave mais je m'en fiche je m'en
fiche royalement après dans les tours
est plus embêtant parce que tu vois tu
investis à deux arrêts mutavie dans un
truc et puis en fait tu vas pas voilà
face c'est complètement différent quoi
sur un truc qui dure six minutes ça me
saoule pas sur un truc que tu as passé
2h30 3h de ta vie c'est relou
donc voilà pourquoi ça me fait beaucoup
plus titre comment sur des tournois
comme le title tuesday ou à où les
arénas et encore les arénas s'était dit
sembiring c'était différent
le cndd à guînes tu peux encore gagner
encore une chance là non et ça
recommence à quelle heure alors je pense
que ça doit pour commencer comment on va
voir ça les carreaux cas les petites ses
comptes marocain voilà les maîtres ça
mais j'avoue je serais partant pour un
petit michel tu ne peux pas chouette
fenêtre au cours de parties oui mais les
mecs vont utiliser un deuxième mort dit
de toute façon ça changera rien et des
mecs de ce niveau là de toute façon ils
vont gruger mails même moi tu vois tu
mets tu mets l'ordi est juste à
quelqu'un qui me dit à 2,3 moment dans
la partie faut jouer tel coucheries tel
coup faut jouer tel coup à deux trois
gros moments franchement alors je vais
pas le gagner toutes les semaines le
title qu'user mais une fois de temps en
temps je vais faire une grosse perf
et si je le fais tout le temps je serai
2900 sur czech com ou de 1950 je dirais
battu un excellent vite ça donc je suis
29,50 tu vas jouer tout le temps que
comme ça donc j'aurai un niveau qui est
très stable par rapport à ce que je fais
et une fois tous les trois quatre
tournois bah voila je fais top 5 est en
fait tu vas jamais faire prendre tu es
bon sur internet et il n'y a jamais
personne qui pourra rien prouvé
donc partant de là si tu veux c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile 16 comme
se débrouille plutôt bien en réalité
mais là tu peux arriver toiture à 2009
vraiment facilement ça se joue vraiment
à pas grand chose ça se joue à trois
quarts même pas trois quatre coups ça je
vois une éval à un coup dans une partie
que je sois à 28 50
rien aucun fun après celle ci tout les
sites sûrs à 1000 dollars par mois
mais bon moi je te dis un truc là
artisanale un tas tu as peut-être des
gens qui sont beaucoup plus avancés qui
ont des logiciels qui tempère les
cookies machin c'est un temps que tu as
toi tu viens te ferai une petite ouais
mais bon là c'est pas en grès général
c'est plutôt pas mal a quand même tu as
les meilleurs joueurs qui sont devant
donc après c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
c'est la vie c'est juste pour expliquer
un petit peu mais quand c'est que des
points d'accord c'est que des points elo
c'est quand même il ya très très peu de
gars qui gruge et les cas qui gruge je
vais vous dire très simplement
généralement c'est en c'est en juillet
août pendant les vacances
et là il y en a un peu plus pendant les
pendants le confinement parce que c'est
des gamins et que c'est des gamins de 14
ans et qu'ils ont rien à faire dehors
life mais mais c'est tout en fait c'est
un pas plus loin
ça va pas plus loin c'est un gamin
évidemment les ans les gens adultes et
normaux et sain d'esprit il semblait pas
puisqu'ils jouent c'est pour ça que tout
au long de l'année
il ya quasi jamais problème c'est à dire
pas ok boomer c'est à dire ok vieux
ouais triché au poker c'est possible
aussi maman mais ram ce blog c'est juste
que tout le monde n'est pas capable de
tricheurs poker quant à un bon niveau
échec c'est pas à toi tu as moins tu me
demanderais triché au poker je sais pas
comment faire vos échecs n'importe quel
bon grand maître sait le faire c'est
très facile
c'est une question messier normes de
grand matin c'est des performances dans
des tournois vrai intrus jolie menace à
tour à je suis 3 prend d'un machin roi
g8 damas sept matches soit défriché
scanner fois sur bay street parce que du
coup on frise sur chaise comme
j'encaisse des billets verts voilà tout
l'intérêt harvey mais quand je suis une
survie de stream non il n'y a pas que
j'ai travaillé je me demande en fait je
pose la question qui jette pas ça me
paraît assez fort mais peut-être un
conseil qu'il ya un truc comme ça mais
inquiets pour un chant d'amour h et
après tu faisais dommage c'était ça
peut-être
j'encaisse des billets verts de temps en
temps ses huit ans que je trime naturel
manche
ouaip le dgi riche et le plus offrant
tout à fait j'arrive chez le plus
offrant
bon bah voilà c'était juste pour vous
expliquer un peu tout le truc juste à
alger pas été reloués avec ça parce
qu'enfant elle a été en réalité
en réalité ça me ça embête pas plus que
ça
des lilas dutil d'osier questions qui
fâchent sérieux 90% de précision ouais
bien sûr c'est justement ça tout le
problème christine on sait que ça peut
arriver
il ya une chance sur 100 de battre m
belle quantité 2003 en blitz
mais ça peut arriver c'est justement le
ça peut arriver qu'il ya un problème et
à 2300 ça peut arriver
le truc en fait c'est que la proportion
performance comme ça qui arrive est
beaucoup trop importante mais tu peux
pas savoir qui le fait de manière les jt
qu'il fait de manière non les gîtes
donc tu pourras jamais savoir c'est
impossible parce que c'est possible
majeur théoriquement un joueur à 2300
peut faire une super partie avec 88% et
pas très mauvais elle c'est possible
vraiment
mais maxime qui a dû perdre après les
partis qui a dû d'utilité qui a du mal à
jouer qui a dû faire n'importe quoi mais
la première partie il a perdu évidemment
c'est possible c'est très improbable
c'est très malin mais c'est possible on
est fou qu'est prend 17
donc à un moment donné en fait fait
chauffage
comment dire problème si plus le tournoi
en lui-même que le truc
tu sauras jamais et du coup tu peux rien
y faire et du coup je jouais pas y
penser
de toute façon pour vous dans le chat a
change quoi on va tomber
vous jouez jamais tournoi ya de l'argent
donc ça changera rien pour moi c'est
relou parce que j'ai envie de jouer ce
tournoi là que j'aime bien et que du
coup maintenant ça m'a fait tilt alors
qu'avant je tu ils étaient pas il n'ya
plus de règles saga s'offrir deux
suivants ouais ça gâche le plaisir de
suivre deux title tuesday dans l'année
quoi tu vois moi nous on a bien qui fait
jusqu'à 45 6 après le truc c'est que dès
que je perds une partie à type qui me
revient très vite avec ce tournoi là
mais sinon ça change rien
toute façon les speech est ce ce sera
toujours cool enfin voilà ouais enfin là
c'était quand même bien cool le début de
tournoi
enfin sur le cours commence à critiquer
ouais mais là c'est parce que j'étais
obligé de commenter sinon j'aurais juste
quitté le tournoi après puis c'était
fini c'était terminé on n'en parlait
plus comme on a fait hier c'est comme on
a fait hier et puis c'est tout on passe
à autre chose
chaque homme fait car où il allait
glisser contre marc ou quoi
ils ont démarré les playoffs bon alors
attend évidemment je les vois pas on va
suivre vu périr
enfin on va suivre les pseudo il faut
que je voie le pseudo il son petit c2b
attend il voit un match après l'autre
je vais aller voir sur les langues
officielles attends attends ouais ok ça
va jouer un match après l'autre que l'on
n'est pas sorti tout de suite alors ça
ils comptent mcg ou au moins là on est
sûr qu'il ya pas de souci je pensais que
du coup il émettrait en eau les matchs
ils émettent comme sa part annoncé
chacun son tour
elle se fait défoncer par am cain vii
nikkei prend la fuite
et ça à faire 1 0
mon favori pour rester au niveau n'est
pas quand même c'est pas mal ce qu'il a
fait avec son carré y sont fous b5 et où
c'est marrant quand il va être
complètement gagnant quand il ya eu
trois âges suisse c'est fini quoi et
merci pour le raid dina option par
rapport au match au jazz manouche bossa
match depuis je n'ai pas vu un message
aux beats on m'a dit que fit route
j'avais gagné ou écoute c'est comme des
matchs semi amicaux donc ça veut pas
dire grand chose belle performance mais
bon on verra ce que ça donne plus tard
sandro la souris ouais non faut faut
raison garder un ces tournois sur
internet s'est pas tu as là par exemple
tapas hikaru tapas mvl t'as pas les
meilleurs ne sont pas dans le top 8
alors que comme je le disais il ya tout
un tas de joueurs l'egypte qui ont quand
même réussi à le faire comme bortnik
est-ce que pornic est plus fort qui car
ou est ce que porte ce qui est plus fort
que que calvel s'ils font un match en 1
v1 il va il va se faire défoncer donc
caruana y est pas non plus
bon c'est raison garder voilà
ne parte et qu'il est bon en canon
novartis est un excellent bits ça si
vous vous rappelez aux championnats du
monde de bulles est l'année dernière il
avait été très bon
non là
mais quand même point suis pas j'ai
arrêté à quoi je suis arrêté à 5 à nice
sur vite ou quelque chose comme ça ou
cinq et demi sur neuf n'est plus mais
j'ai arrêté de jouer sérieux aka à 4 4
sur 6 soit
j'ai pas les calmants ya pas les gamins
par contre les autres on les cas mais
moi je les ai pas apparemment mon prêt
bas de façon c'est une défonce à dans
cette partie alors si on prend des cinq
la tour qui va arriver en vain
donc ça va faire 1 0 ouais il ya eu de
belles parties moi j'ai fait d'autres 2
3 mètres mais même contre part à vianne
en fait je me suis raté mais la partie
elle était intéressante
la partie était intéressante la tour qui
arrive en 1/4 trois pièces pour la dame
mais à mon longue ça doit être
complètement gagnant jusqu'à quand même
beaucoup de pions et à des six est bien
joué je pense quoique roi des 8
on est aura un corps mène donc ça
revient au même
voilà ce qu'on doit essayer dé bonne
partie pour la partie d'avant était
vraiment bien
pranger 6 de ses 7 à 3,8 dame s'est mis
trois sets am prend 17 à l idée c'est
que le roi doit aller là arrimé au quai
table aussi sur un fief cet enfer dame
s'est vite et ouais mais fou et recettes
la protège la tour il a raté ça il va
peut-être tomber ça il a raté niall et
maintenant c'est plus si simple adam g 4
il a raté sa part a aidé à me produire
et là c'est fini
ok ça à faire 1-0 et je crois que 102 je
crois que c'est un match aller retour
donc
il calcule soit ouais mais il a fait une
faute de calcul quand même ce que dame
e6 et où il aurait fait dame c86 non
donc il a fait une faute de calcul mais
autour des 1 après il y avait le petit
zigzag avec les échecs
bien que ce match en cours ouais je
pense est aussi qu'il y aurait tous les
matches qui se joueront en même temps
mais non les matches vous êtes séparés
sa faim ça continue en 3 0 ou sa
mobylette ça je sais pas si nous on n'a
pas écrit ça c'était un peu à l'arraché
on va on va le découvrir
voilà en tout cas pas ram qui est obligé
de gagner je sais de la rendre de
l'espagnol avec le sacrifice de pions
c'était europe ces deux braves qui était
de mauvaise foi pas à padoue bof c'est
qu'ils favorisent ce match
un bas de bas ça doit être plutôt par am
mais maintenant que neil stein a gagné
la première c'est plutôt ni alain du
goût vue qui mène au score jusque unieux
le fait gagner quand les menaces mal
tant de damages de damas chain
votre épée une charge et 3 j'aurais fait
cavaler avec 4 persos ma chance il va
échanger en vain
je pensais qu'il y avait des changements
et m anne 44.94 est ok la tête pour
prendre un car et des f4 qui est
possible ce que je suis parti politique
en russie ou plus ou moins - que plus
peut-être on va voir
voir comment ça continue les deux fous
sont quand même bien braqués sur le roi
pour le prix d'un pion s'écoule à jouer
pour les noirs maintenant tu trouves pas
que l'échec se font un peu acheter
l'émergence du tour a pris aux pieds
pharaonique qui remplacent peu à peu les
cyclos soutenant je trouve pas à lui de
surf ou après moi je trouve que c'est
pour moi ce qui est dommage c'est lé
budget pharaonique avec en face 0
audience moi je suis plutôt content
qu'ils aient des budgets petit personnel
qui est des gros budget pour les thons à
des chèques
après ce que j'aimerais bien c'est que
les gros budget soit en corrélation avec
l'audience qu'ils apportent moi c'est
plus ça moi c'est plus ça le truc
le fait qu'ils aient des gros budgets
après c'est tant mieux et c'est tant
mieux qu'ils aient plus d'argent pour
les joueurs et c'est tant mieux que
c'est tant mieux que les échecs se
développent et qu'ils attirent des
mécènes le seul truc qui est dommage
voilà pour moi c'est que ces grains du
goût tu t'attendrai comme il ya beaucoup
d'argent investi hors genre de retour
sur investissement une certaine hype
pour les tournois et c'est pas le cas et
je trouve c'est ça qui est dommage
surtout pas le fait qu'ils aient plus de
tournois obligeant par icloud cash price
c'est difficile parce qu'ils ont souvent
les joueurs ont un cachet qui n'est pas
communiqué mais pour des gros tronc à
des chèques
il doit y avoir de plusieurs centaines
de milliers à avoir millions de prix
pour les tournois
les joueurs sont obligés d'attendre ce
match mais apparemment elle ouais
l'approché classique c'était vraiment
bien fait partie des compètes que j'aime
bien protégé s'il fait partie des
compétitions qui me plaisent la mairie
voit la province et c'est juste le la
petite frustration c'est que les
tournois classiques font du classique et
ça c'est tant mieux
ea et le truc dommage c'est c'est que du
coup comme ils n'ont pas d'obligation de
machin de trucs comme les fédérations et
tout et tout ça des obligations par
rapport à l'histoire du jeu par rapport
à tout un tas de choses je trouve un
petit peu dommage que du coup il faut 10
face quasiment jamais voir jamais
d'événements vraiment intéressant le
problème est pointée surtout c'est que
les budgets pharaoniques aux grappes
avec une bonne organisation il faut avec
les messins agissent avec les
organisateurs pse mille bas on est 100%
gay encore le bit surf ou mais ça c'est
pas près d'arriver dans les échecs
donc après c'est moi ça fait plus d'une
dizaine d'années se fait une vingtaine
d'années que je vois ça et il n'y a pas
vraiment d'évolution là tu laisses et
j'ai envie de te dire il faut pas faut
être plutôt positif par rapport à ça
tant pis pas grave en fait du fait de
l'émergence d'internet du fait qu'on
puisse stream et qu'on puisse faire des
event et où on peut encore réussir à
faire des evènes coule entre nous happer
pouces tu vois faire des trucs sympas et
finalement on n'a plus à on n'a plus à
s'embêter être frustré de ça il ya dix
ans c'était beaucoup plus frustrant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tu veux ta
caméra tu fais un stream déjà en garde
il kiffe tranquille paix poussif et des
petits trucs entre toi et puis tu vois
là pas si c'est pas si grave en vrai
c'est comme ça
d'abord je sais que c'est bien mais
c'est demandant bien parce qu'avec un
peu de cas gilles choughri firoud de
jeunes canadiens donc palmarès donne un
million abus stream on a une carlson
hikaru ça va bien se passer
ouais bon après kreattur pranger 22.3
n'en assure dame prenait 3 ya toujours
huit tours à huit tours de leur tour
alors ouais et dame prend 1,3 au
prochain il y aura encore droit j'ai un
méta me prend à eux deux et par am qui
va se faire éliminer dès le premier tour
ouais mais là la finale il la gagne
jamais fawcett encore peut-être mais ça
à faire nul au pire mais la prod chea
sim non non c'est sympa comme événement
après voilà il ya peut-être quelques
petites choses à améliorer et c'est mais
je trouve que globalement c'est plutôt
bien quand même
param param va la perdre va se faire
éliminer par nial sarine qui
impressionne il joue bien aujourd'hui
c'est des bonnes game il fait fait de
bons résultats alors je pense que vous
prend ses quatre doigts gagnaire et g3
peut-être là je vois la connexion param
param bosse pas assez vrai et ça fait 2
r donc par am qui à mon avis est éliminé
et maintenant est ce qu'on va voir notre
ouais on va avoir
artak à isabelle contre arthur à valian
ouais donc joueurs australiens annoncé
peut-être un jour avec drapeaux stress
c'est peut-être un arménien face à un
noir mais n'y a en tout cas
arthur à valian donc le maître fils
d'arméniens qui qui a fait des grosses
pertes jusqu'à maintenant un petit peu
l'épouvantail du tournoi après ski
l'arménien d'origine arménienne on sait
pas mais il a un certain style c'est un
russe serait du coup sa ruse d'origine
arménienne dont qui a fait de belles
perfs qui a fait une excellente partie à
la dernière contre meilleur c'est un
joueur connu n'en pas du tout alors pour
le moment je crois pas que ce soit parti
un style naturel way we care without
s'est fait éliminer qui s'est fait
sortir
donc on va voir je pense que ceux qui
vont jouer en prochain je vois pas pour
le monde réalise des parties en cours
kas fait ça mais est ce que n'a qu'à
s'ils avaient gagné la guerre contre
hitler il y serait à trépasser charles
voir comment il joue et on va voir on va
voir je pense qu'il va se faire sortir
de manière très expéditif
personnellement je pense qu'il va se
faire sortir de manière très expéditive
brent sutter qui est connu pour être un
excellent buteur après je voyais car au
dessus mais bon il ya roues comme vous
aider j'ai déjà l'impression qu'ils
commencent à avoir du mal à jouer dans
cette title deviner la notion ceux qui
passent séparemment est pas sûr qu'ils
seraient pas c est qu à rouen
on va voir ça joue alors ouais ça vient
de partir ça vient de s'allumer sur mon
truc aussi en contrepartie portes il ya
un excellent joueur de bliss et et
bullet sur internet c'est un excellent
joueur se portent ni vraiment bien les
battures mtl way en bullet c'est
vraiment à le voir difficile d'avoir ce
cadre est supérie quoi je participe et
je me suis éliminé
mais je vais fait éliminer serait
probablement papa c'est vrai
ça paraît plutôt correct comme position
pour les deux joueurs truc c'est fermé
pour ménage moi je m'attend je m'attends
à une histoire de porte chance mais je
vous dis tout de suite je suis éliminé
avec toi et tu essaies fort un moyen
peut-être une bonne parodie ferme tout
il va faire nul doute un peu
position est facile à jouer pour les
blancs mais reprendre du pur et avec le
pian h5 il va faire nul dans la première
déjà on verra la deuxième il refuse nul
avec les blancs formaient pas se passer
grand chose
ont tout fait pour faire nul avec les
blancs je vois pas prem sexy fait fca
tuera le pion qui arrivant aux cinq
l'allant du flash cinq piscines la nulle
ou tu fais tu as tout ranger ici c'est à
temps sont a pas moyen de percer 5
mètres le cavalier angers 6
mais en fait quand bien même temps ferme
la tourache set tu peux pas à percer et
s'affèrent nul et on va voir la deuxième
qu'elle avait maintenant une victoire de
pornic assez facile on va voir
ça joue vite winston lui est fait non je
te trompes victoire de pornic easy
ok y'a plus au centre en premier
merci à diablo piano pour le seul merci
tonton prendre ne joue pas mal hein
qui joue pas mal et la dame prend 5
il faut aussi ce bon mot et blanc un bel
avantage de simples pions plus il n'ya
pas l'animation fesseur passion à la
chaîne chez scor antonymes là le
cavalier qui va aller vers ces cinq
allers vers f4 et p4 bien joué
on va voir
mais là les blancs sont vraiment bien si
leur du boeuf
tu t'attends à une victoire de double
off je m'attends à une victoire de dubaï
ils vont faire en est rien
donc
dans le tank donc née partenia très
indécis ouais c'est pas si bizarre que
ça monsieur p soit pour un cas j'en ai
déjà parlé et reparlé
je veux le redire mais je pense juste
qu'il tilt dans ces tournois et qu' il
peut plus jouer mais je savais que
c'était juste une faute non mais c'est
sûr qu'il va perdre ribéry s'alléger
aucun doute sur l'issue de ce match
j'ai juste aucun doute la moins d'un
muscle icloud un truc incroyable ce
qu'il va perdre
donc
c'est sûr de ses chevauchées sur il est
trop fort portiques bortnik et
ukrainiens mais ils habitent aux états
unis alors peut-être qu'il est
maintenant à iliad est une il ya déjà
des tu dois je pense pour les antilles
soit éliminé maintenant logiquement
quand ils font un tableau c'est qu'il ya
déjà des thunes
dommage pour lui qui allait tour sinon
ils auraient pu reprendre et b2 le
gagnant gagne 5000 dollars cisco
ouais c'est fini j'étais sûr que martin
gagnerait c'était évident c'était
évident mais les gouvernements futurs
avec les noirs et enfin 8 c'est fini
mais voilà éliminé
c'était 100% sûr parce que ça a l'air un
peu mais 99% alors nepomniachi artemiev
le prochain match
on va voir ce que ça donne
[Musique]
moi je mettrais quand même une pièce sur
les peaux on va voir
on va voir tu me sur un dépôt personnes
tu penses quoi de l'open de six gestes
qui se jouera en ligne a pas grand chose
j'en pense pas grand chose
je n'en pense pas grand chose
alors n'est pas déjà en lice on n'arrive
pas à organiser des tournois correct
alors en longues
je comprends pas trop le délire mais bon
mélange oyedepo gagner
merci anthony pour le tweet frei merci
tonton allez c'est parti
moi je vois bien inial sign éliminé
pornic après mais bon j'ai pas être sa
petite variante à la petite finale avec
des oeufs des oeufs et fait roi reprend
d un ces trois mois ces deux des bonnes
soirées jazz fritz et tu joues pour ta
petite finale pourquoi pas vraiment une
pièce très bas écoute pour avoir toi
alors qu'il est en d2 cette finale quoi
je pense que c'est maintenant qu'il faut
par marc prend pourtant dernier coûte je
sais pas mais c'est un ton amical encore
un les gars on va le regarder ensemble
ce sera sympa mais c'est pas mon temps à
des jeunes sera plus intéressant que ce
tournoi là mon avis parce que quand même
c'est semi officielle et est ok les
jeunes live ont elles ont vu le truc
sens large qu'on sera sympa quand même
le tournoi de ce week-end artemiev pas
et tenait un double effet des champions
du monde
pour avoir ya quand même un gros enjeu
là maintenant merci à monsieur filage
pour les 100 beats en même temps à des
jeunes quelque part way pas pour nous
comme cents à l'équipe de france est où
mon petit plus un pour les blancs c'est
chiant à jouer avec les noirs sa dalle
pion aux 5 un peu mal talent cavaliers
assiste à l'espace pour les blancs à
lille dame
ouais les tournois en ligne
après les échecs ont pas encore pris le
tournant des gros tournois en ligne
ce hacker le strict faire demain c'est à
20h30 mais ce sera face tout seul
meiway n'ont ni toit ni sa part on n'a
pas encore pris le le truc aux échecs
donc
je trouve ça dur à jouer avec les noirs
c'est une affaire d'usagé pour du g5 à
relief quatre cavaliers f4 directement
fouet fait un truc c'est que les blancs
ils défendent tout il ya le roi qui va
venir ans est de la lgv qui revient à f2
regardez ces fouilles sont magnifiques
après j'ai trop la vitrine cup en effet
ce week-end avait vraiment format cool
après c'est sûr c'est moi qui les fais
donc forcément j'aime bien le format que
j'ai fait mais à j'ai trouvé que c'était
assez rapide et dynamique mais que ça a
duré juste le temps qu'il fallait ce que
ça a fait aller les demi-finales au
final ça fait ça fait une heure de jeu
et 40 du ca fait 1h40 de jeu avec une
pause de 20 minutes au milieu et qui te
pose entre les mutants de cinq minutes
donc ouais ça paraissait bien et le
dimanche la bombe à la finale a été un
peu un peu expéditive mais ça fait un
événement d'une heure mais j'ai trouvé
que c'était assez dynamique et assez
cool ce sa page trouve quand ça dure
longtemps après c'est un peu longuet
elle a été prouvée cinq ans il se fait
défoncer à la rtbf
j'ai trouvé ça sympa
perso
après comme je disais comme c'est moi
qui ai écrit le format forcément ça me
paraît être un format est cool mais je
pense qu'en général un évène sportif qui
dure plus de 2h 2h30 ça devient long
d'un point de vue général je crois que
trois heures ça doit vraiment être ton
max après trois plus de vrai mais dès sa
sauce et gaza c'est un truc caritatif
veut pas que les jouets ariza jouer à
100% si ça avait été un truc avec de
l'argent n'aurait pas fait trois on
arrive sûrement fait 3 + 1 ou 3 + 2 mai
à mais là quand même pas c'est là pour
le fun ouais finale de grand chelem en
cinq sets way est complètement mais je
pense qu'en général
mise à part un truc qui pourrait être
vraiment long parce que c'est une finale
ou quoi je pense que quand tu restes pas
les 3 heures maximum nature est déjà là
cet event il est déjà à 3h20 sur une
seule journée peut-être le faire sur
deux journées le tournoi et table au
lendemain ou un truc comme ça au vaccin
est un peu les blancs bas ils ont une
pièce de plus après les blancs
donc on ils ont un peu ric scène maison
une pièce de plus le super bowl sur plus
de quatre heures ouais mais parce qu'il
ya les pubs et tout mais en terme de jeu
effectif t'as quoi tu es à une heure et
quelques métal concert au milieu talent
machin ils font un tas de pub pour les
annonceurs oui maman qui donne une pièce
il avait une poubelle intergalactique
bobby fischer est ce que un truc de
jesus a commenté et je crois que le
commenter la finale mais le tournoi
qu'il est parti d'une heure la voix
c'est sûr que je commenterai pas quoi
qu'il en soit ouais super bowl c'est une
fête et à tout un tas de trucs qui se
passent mais en gros les compétitions
avec plus de 2 3 heures de jeu
consécutifs c'est sont des exceptions
il peut il peut être un peu dans la
merde mais peut quand même
j'ai visionné une poêle intergalactique
le goff ses cinq frères et c'est sympa
ça reste quand même rarissime mais il
s'est fait lycée ici il ya en train de
se faire maquiller n'est pas le truc
c'est qu'il a plus de temps au tour de
france ces étapes sont oui mais ils sont
pas retransmise en nous en large et en
travers
y'a que les grosses étapes de montagne
attendent est tombé huit tours b
satisfait mater nepos est incroyable et
tout repenser 8 c'est impressionnant
comme il sait pharma qui l'avait pièce
de plus dans un truc pas si compliqué
que ça
faire un peu dur mais pas super dur et
il s'est fait arnaquer
non aux échecs trucks il faut être
concentré au cir est plusieurs à
regarder c'est fou bon une époque qui
pour moi était favori maintenant
évidemment avec les blancs artemiev
rexel j'avais raison failover xtendnet
sont rois
le trophée chopard c'était vraiment bien
car tout et c'était là un excellent
format pour le mans ils n'ont pas
commencé la deuxième partie je pas ce
qu'ils font
il a craqué prochaine invite beyoncé
mary pop singer on essaiera d'avoir
cette année je peux le dire maintenant
on a essayé d'avoir un accueil firoud
jack on n'avait pas réussi à avoir
peut-être cette fois-ci ça peut-être la
prochaine fois ça on a quand même
récolté une grosse sommes peut-être qui
se prêteront plus au jeu ils ont
probablement pensé que ce serait un truc
tout petit quoi mais peut-être que la
prochaine ferme pour organiser une
grosse cote
on verra maka je pense ça devrait
pouvoir le faire
la prochaine fois
quand sera-t-on rémunérateur il faut pas
aux échecs aux fins et je sais pas
prison reina cas il avait un truc prévue
de longue date en fait avec le président
d raptor le dimanche soir qui pouvait
passer un truc prévue de longue date ils
pouvaient pas se libérer six rounds je
sais pas il était un truc je sais juste
pas envie aussi enfants ça prend du
temps c'est c'était plus étonnant que
maxime accepte que les autres refusant
ja c'est plus étonnant le côté
d'accepter que refusé quoi le président
des houston rockets this way mais du
coup la vue les dons qui a eu quoi
nakhal c'est sûr qu'il accepterait
quasiment je pense du coup
ouais peut-être il a après pour prouver
sur trois points comme je sais pas il ya
peut-être une raison qu'on connaît pas
mais agir c'est sur toi c'est surtout
max et baky qui ont été super sympa de
venir au delà de ça
donc
donc donc donc
non donc un peu le chat comportement ça
a joué
[Musique]
s'arrêter bonnac havrais je pense ça
peut être jouable pour une prochaine
édition
la vie c'est mal tombé en terme de date
il m'a répondu un haka est juste est mal
tombé en terme de date
c'est un temps assez salement mais il se
débrouille bien sage et 4 faut avoir
envie quand même dans un must d'euros
donc bref la documentaire s'arrêter
s'arrêter picouet il aurait dit que tout
le monde est nul
avec ma ktm bien ouais il aime bien il
aime bien ouais après ça aurait ce
serait possible d'être fort prochaine
fois et d'avoir des grosses trimer comme
gotaga ou quoi je sait pas aucune idée
mais à la voulais surtout faire un truc
d'échec plus tôt je l'adoré convient dès
l'aube à blainville à 26,72 là ce serait
vraiment épique
on verra on verra la prochaine fois no
fake
si on se refait ça l'année prochaine nos
feuilles qu'on on contactera hikaru
autant que sam hamad a quand même été
champion d'europe et 18e mondiale
maestro a cédé donc raison qu'il a
beaucoup de forêts
il ya des enfants malades n'ont
heureusement j'ai envie de dire mais je
vois n'est pas égalisé perso quand même
la partie à tour depuis longtemps ça
tourne il se passe pas grand chose mais
justement ça peut être al'avantage de
dépôt qui se passe rien de 1872 le
navara plus
et ouais mais michel michel talent est
là dès maintenant et divorcée vlad vlad
et en quart de finale de coupe du monde
contre kasparov guillaume que l'année
prochaine au baby soeur pour moi pas
faire appel à la générosité tout le
monde tous les trois mois
bon
qui se passe pas grand chose dans cette
partie autre invité marc alex trimble a
de gros intérêts
ça ce serait une bonne idée 1 oui même
dans ces mêmes dans un événement
caritatif il n'est pas capable d'élever
son niveau de jeu
bon il ne le fait pas exprès il est
vraiment très très nul savait que ça
serait marrant
donc
c'est vrai que ce serait marrant tornade
en navarre robert s navarra avoir une
coupe comme ça quoi il car vous tous les
pôles française qui vit tous les tous
les gars de la chaîne quoi il est
probable est qu'ils joueraient un
premier tournant mais il faudrait il
faudrait peut-être faire un truc comme
ça et la prochaine fois car ou quand
même s contre hikaru c'est la s il se
fait défoncer art akouè grand favori de
la compétition
bon alors le roi qui va arriver en b ici
s'il va encaisser le pion tout cas ça
semble être son idée échangerait prend
2,5 à est gentil prend là il veut
reprendre là et a envoyé son pion non
ils jouent ça comme ça
elle ment il va peut-être faire rue le
pion venant cavaliers f/4 5-5 ouais il
va apprendre d'eux est peut-être aussi
savent bien jouer membranes et pau qui a
pris 2 r surprenant
est ce que j'ai constaté de
personnalités connues en france qui joue
aux échecs non j'ai trop pas vraiment je
laisse les gens en contact et s'ils le
souhaitent un
donc
donc donc tolérés bassett et kiev qui
m'avait contacté ouais mais après là
pour la vitrine cup c'était pas
forcément possible de le contacter dans
le sang soit c'était un truc où il y
avait que des gens qui jouent aux échecs
jusqu'au des gens forts on a essayé de
faire un truc comme ça on va voir chat
de nespouls en pls way
enfin une nouvelle soirée dans ce fameux
bar oui mais là encore pour le moment
c'est difficile à prévoir
je suis une pièce sur dubaï maintenant
alors seydou ba ouai double of dubai
favori brassard enchaîné comment tu
expliques que leur j'aime je déjoue mais
il joue de quoi en fait
par là il a juste perdu contre avec
super fort enfin j'veux pas tu perds
contre artemiev enfin ses choix artemiev
l'effort arthémy enfin c'est pas une
honte de se faire éliminer par artemiev
finale ou artemiev peut-être comme
impressionnant artemiev sarine peut-être
on va voir
on va voir peut-être artemis sarine on
va on va voir ce que ça donne
pour le moment ça joue pas on va voir ce
que ça donne un ca pas encore commencé
tu es un peu sur le téléphone pour
essayer de choper quand ça commence pour
pas rater en fait
donc ça va bientôt commencer j'espère
n'ont pas encore
on va voir un mois je plutôt pour d-box
que je suis plus copain avec lui dans la
vraie vie que je vis de leurs du coup on
va voir ça veut rien dire parce que je
connais vu ce qu'il va gagner
ça ne veut absolument rien dire
bon c'est vrai au fouet je connais un
peu du waf je connais un peu double off
du coup c'est un gars que j'aime bien
du coup c'est un gars que j'aime bien et
donc mais donc on va dire que je vais
être plus tôt pour lui aura pas de
synchro mais c'est un gars que j'aime
bien on se connaît un peu quaretta
mangeons ensemble plusieurs fois et je
connais ce vide leur envoyais je connais
siedler aussi et pour moi doit fait
mille fois plus sympas mais après ça tu
sais c'est une question à percer à et le
gars qui m'a battu tout à l'heure et je
me disais bien qu'il était bon le
quellec view des jouets qui étaient 26
56 à 27,70 ça j'ai bien senti que que ça
j'aurais bien ça joue pas pour l'instant
on va voir
alors c'est pas encore parti ça va
bientôt partir
donc
dans le tank donc
je sais pas trop quoi vous dire je pas
quand ça repart
alors ça y est c'est parti alors vite
leur avec les plans dans des lots
comparables sur czech comme pour moi
c'est 50 50
on verra bien on verra bien dans cette
petite anglaise qui s'est transformée
genre de tarage avec le pion qui est
venu en d4 avec avec le contrôle du coût
du pion à eux deux fait un pion isolé en
d4 et de l'autre côté tu as un pion
arriérés je sois échangé et tu peux
faire fou prend p prend dame prend des
cats et gagner le pion mais ça doit pas
grand-chose grand chose je me dis que ce
soit être théorique a d'ailleurs fait tu
reprends de la dame russie ou pour le
flash
tu sais pas mais en gros ça doigts pour
que doit jouer aussi vite c'est que ça
doit aller
bon alors là il met une pression sur le
quart à liessies fait quand je fais
prise prises quelles façons toujours à
apprendre du cavalier pourra peut-être
te mettre le feu en dessin qu'on h3 et
jouer les cases blanches l'imaginent
c'est la nouveauté un peu dithyrambique
huawei pour les analyses a pris
peut-être pas forcément en tant que
joueur après peut-être pas forcément
tant que joueur mais en tant qu'analyste
ouais bon alors pour vuitton qui joue la
colonne cavaliers à 5 images ou la casse
b3 moi j'aime bien les noirs écouter
personnellement je sais plus facile à
jouer en blitz par après ça va être
sensiblement égal mais enfin je trouve
que c'est bien il a sa petite position
sage ou non une position tout à fait
corrects voir comment il fait évoluer sa
mais sa position est agréable
je me donne un peu arriérés
a tenté ensuite je peux faire du four b3
qui sait qu'à tout moment
bon mais celui-là il fait un truc par un
canal font g2 qui attaquent bessette
il interdit tout reprend c'est à cause
d'un 3,8 damas quatre c'est pas mal joué
et maintenant sur four b3 il va venir en
b 4 sûrement il va toucher les pions est
peut-être que ça tourne un peu en faveur
de ce vide l'air peut-être que c'est en
train de tourner un peu en faveur de
suite l'air il fait g5
ouais alors il n'a pas trop d'idées de
base
il prend de l'espace mais prendre
l'espace que dame b 4 clairement il veut
prendre le pion maintenant il laisse
peut-être l'occasion d'échanger tout un
coup de fouet pour protéger latéralement
et attaquer le pion à eux deux ils
commencent parfois elle sa chance et
qu'il échangerait qui ferez fouet f5
mais bon peut-être tapper un jour de
prendre un tour c'est 8 à la suite qui
peut être dangereux monk être seul tour
c'est 8
c'est un grand tour et 8 du coup la
question c'est ce que tu veux na sera
vraiment de prendre à eux deux donc
g7 j'aime bien après il ya un petit
problème avec le 4e vail qui a du mal à
revenir en jeu pour tous bof c'est quand
même une grosse question de savoir s'il
va pouvoir le ramener oui parce que pour
le moment si genre tu es fou des trois
pions des tropes que ce soit bien
visuelle mois la fouer cap et stu
échange on voit bien que le fou g2 est
beaucoup plus fort que le cavalier
villar qui domine un c'est sûr carlier
très mal passé et peut-être qu'il a raté
p4 qui citait les c6 est un grand b 6
mais peut-être qu'à et b3 ouais d'accord
peut-être qu'il n'a rien raté
l'accueil ces six semaines le cavalière
vient en jeu et à lyon 2-2 en l'air bon
l'avantagent des blancs a disparu
avantage des blancs a disparu bon il
peut encore essayer de jouer s'il veut
sur bea qui avance puis on pas
s'éloigner rend un peu faible pardon
donc l'on peut gagner un pion par
d'apprentis si ça me prend des trois
dames français 6 mai y aura des échecs y
aura les pulsions passer ça je pensais
juste nul mais après peut-être je me
trompe je vois pas comment il peut faire
mieux perpète
ouais le pion des trop fort et tu peux
pas bon du coup parti retour
c'était très équilibrée la première
belle partie on va voir comment se joue
le retour
bon ça jouait d'anglais symétrique
kenyan b5 alors est ce que ces théories
qu'on a pas mal que korn est pour nous
le dira mais bon vu le nombre de coups
qui a ça doit l'être mais les joueurs
doivent pas forcément savoir est ce que
tu fais un fou 3 ici pour attaquer la
dame m² en d4 après paraît logique
bonsoir et théorique mais je dois juste
plus rappelé bonne nuit à ambo and à
demain du coup pour l'émission de fab
donc pourquoi pas qui a et des cadres
direct je comprends pas trop prier
réfléchi au temps
il fait qu'hériter 4 t'affecter qui va
revenir en v3 exactement madame ans et 7
et ça donne sa déposition de sicile in
time à 900 kg ont eu quatre bon ça doit
aller 1
ça doit aller
après donc on va arriver aux demi
finales après ça on sera en demi mais
qu'as tu as fait refouler 2 et rock
north bay 5 prendre le pion se paraît
dangereux mais il se passe quoi
concrètement
et peut-être quelque chose comme ça avec
un problème dans la diagonale et après
une fois cette cave et 5
qui a été quatre qui y jouent le double
courage et dame prend jambé cassée bien
placé et protégé par le fouet fuite
du coup il tuera bouffer et d'un autre
côté il bloque un peu à 2
donc
ça a l'air d'être cool pour les noirs et
en plus c'est l'ennemi davance waroquet
mais il va faire fouet cette rock avec
les noirs et là pions beckham qui est
super fort les choses leader ce soir il
a déjà battu na ka na il fait une grosse
perte mais on sait qu'il est capable un
dealer bonvin gros jour de bien jouer
comme ça la question n'est pas de savoir
si les noirs sont nés ou passer ses
nerfs vont réussir à gagner très
clairement le leader tu va vouloir
terminer le match difficile qui va
prendre des 3 et rock l'imaginent des
cinq peut-être en fait pourquoi rockets
tu veux avoir concurrents des 5 parce
que bas il va juste prendre le centre et
hongrois peut-être que le ramener vers
ces six s'est joué
à quatre il va se débarrasser du
puy-en-velay 4 qui était pénible et
carrier des cats ok mais il s à 2 qui
n'est pas jouée à deux ça pouvait être
un coup à ce qui était pas facile à
reprendre le pion en tout cas il a un
avantage avec les noirs objectivement ça
doit pas être suffisant mais il va
essayer d' un peu pressé après ça peut
se retourner aussi un ambitieux avec
quelques secondes sur la pendule qui
revient conception de plus mais en
orbite ce pas évident je veux les coûts
précis allez quand même trente secondes
de plus pour ce vide l'air vraiment
c'est chaud
c'est chaud parce que le carillon est un
qui menaçait vii et c'est difficile de
s'organiser ça peut voir en tournée d'un
côté ou de l'autre ici très très
difficile de dire quand on revient il
revient en bessette il attaque le fou il
va pouvoir faire car et les prend à vii
est menacée qui est des 6 et
probablement même les blancs maintenant
qu'ils sont mieux
ouais ben et 8 pour échanger et la tour
qui par là bah oui c'est bien joué pour
maintenant avec les blancs tu as envie
de jouer parce que tu te dis que la
partie à la tournée dans ton en ta
faveur
wen qui va taper une pulsion le drap
taper le pion f2 qui pousse f5 et g4 le
retour bien jouer il va laisser faire
car il y avait sept tentes et le match
et si seul coup là il n'y a rien il va
faire que cinq échecs et prend là nul
voilà c'est ce qu'il est en train de
faire grief 3 elle va faire 4 et f3 bon
c'est pas encore féfé 3e set mais tour
f5 non à tour f3 sur mon tour prendre
entre trois et cavaliers 5
instagram 33 3 5
ça peut finir sur une fourchette à
d'accord ça ça liquide comme sarrois f2
et ça va échanger les pions il a fait
une deuxième nul alors c'est quoi les
règles maintenant j'en sais rien je n'en
sais rien
je n'en ai aucune idée
je peux être trouvé sur la chaîne
officielle
tout cas c'est chaud hein ces shows the
night
je vais essayer de regarder je pense que
ça joue à l'armageddon
un vrai
donc
la personne qui a écrit ça
je sais pas en fait un mag et devrait
donc armageddon en cas de nul les noirs
sont qualifiés en cas de victoire
blanche chez les blancs et on va voir ce
que ça donne du coup à plus 2 nuls
du coup plus de nul possible las après
celle là ça ira forcément en demi finale
voir ce que ça donne
comment si je les vends généralement
c'est un tirage au sort ouais voilà
d'après les règles dans le tournoi il ya
un des deux joueurs qui décident à la
cedh ou boivent qui allaient blanc
attend c'est vraiment un armageddon
ah oui ok ils ont mis un truc pour
enlever demi tonnoir d'accord donc
wilaya iv 00h05 pour double off et la
cadence c'est sans un crémant donc ça
peut flag met donc c'est un genre de
grun fed avec des quatre qui a été
retardé et tout beau activement un peu à
l'alpha 0 qui envoie le pion ash ouais
jouer avec d'énormes armageddon c'est
pour les pleutres on est d'accord on va
voir ce que ça va donner
il a fait des six d'accord why not
fameux 3 pourquoi un différentiel
puisque les blonds l'objectif dans
l'obligation de gagner donc pour
équilibrer ils ont un peu plus de temps
dans armageddon jaillard à jouer à 60e
winship astral quoi là je sais pas il ya
différentes sectes armageddon envoyé un
pion à je viens d'alpha 0 bombe larsen
le faisait déjà à l'époque mais c'est
vraiment alpha 0 qui a relancé la mode
on va dire qu'il ya développé ce truc-là
redévelopper ce truc là mais vous
trouvez que ça équilibre
ouais ouais
suivant les styles il ya des gars qui
préfèrent les blancs il ya il préfère
les noirs il n'y a pas de consensus sur
ce qui est mieux moi je prendrais les
blancs toujours pas ce que je préfère
jouer pour gagner j'ai un objectif plus
clair mais il ya des gens qui défendent
très bien le faire les noirs peut
dépendre des adversaires aussi
du coup du bois va prendre plus de
risques way puis moi j'ai besoin de
temps donc en plus j'ai plus de temps et
des stats sur garde longtemps avec donc
je crois que ces avantages au noir
quand vous voyez un pion angers ici ce
petit rock h 4 h 5 sacrifice match oui
mais enfin ça existe depuis longtemps
mais c'était un peu sorti de mode
d'abord dans les parties de fisher à
l'époque où quoi les joueurs prenaient
quand même d'abord le centre ou quoi
radio il a fait h4 en laissant des
pièces complètement non développé du
beau saint geoirs date à quoi est ce un
jour original j'avais plutôt d'attac
on va voir bon il fait des trois coups
pour faire jouer fou brel a vraiment la
position qu'ils voulaient avec les
blancs il a beaucoup d' attaque presque
fou d ici c'est un coup ici je m l'ordi
pour voir dan f6 on ici dame france et 3
est le truc c'est kayal fou qui arrivant
j'ai quatre et ça fait mal et si le
rapport avec des douars du fou des
quatre d'accord ok c'est ça l'idée
d'être obligé de faire tourner 05 quoi
mais touré 8 maintenant par et c'est
hyper compliqué extrêmement compliqué
qu'un position ouais je vois poindre
plutôt les noirs mais bon les joueurs
sont assez plein d'autres niveaux
mais la tête rock est un coût 1 pour ce
pareil que le roi et commence à attaquer
f7 croisée de aussi peut être une idée
je sais pas mais je rien notre côté tu
perds le roi des deux c'est le temps de
faire roi des deux tours tours b f1 ce
serait génial
voilà la raison de prendre le temps de
réfléchir parce que quel point ça peut
être tentant aussi on apprend être set
ça tu vas pas faire
quel point c'était pas très tentant
lahrache quatre matches quatre défaites
il mena il peut me lasser quelque chose
mais quoi qu'elle est adams et 4 c'est
fini je pensais dame c4 en fait c'était
l'idée mais la dame c4 sur watch 8es
cavalia statut gagne la dame a long way
mais il n'y a pas de coups en fait cet
abcès car c'est ici
bref lui qui avoue prendre mon tout
bêtement et royal suite cavaliers à vii
puis qu'on l'envoie en fait ben c4 c'est
juste game over
je pensais que d'un match 4 c'était
l'idée oui ces filles là ces abandons
direct maillard il a abandonné direct
ouais donc bien ce que je disais c'est
pas toujours
il faut aussi ce qui est prend aussi ce
bon passage vous même pas en fait pas
déjà pièces de moins et à la taille car
la dame attaqué il ya tout ouais donc
les blancs tu vois qui joue la tacc
villard out
bref si c'était une grosse gaffe
bon après l'avez peut-être une position
difficile à jouer aux anciens
donc ça veut dire qu après la demi
finale ce sera sarine contre bortnik
aller moi je voulais sarine favori après
ses shows
et de l'autre côté du bois faut retenir
ça va être chaud les gens qui pensaient
que les noirs étaient favoris sont en
sueur n'épouse sortie c'est dingue ouais
mais après artemiev il a sorti les
grosse game un parti car mon nom james
de de gm soviétique imbattable sporting
surtout le nom du méchant dans sonic non
si je ne me trompe pas
assez robotnik ouais bon c'était pas
loin jeunes est une page de pub ce
qu'ils ont les pubs sur le truc officiel
aussi et les arénas qui vont commencer
le attend premium arenas et le 3 mais
finalement ils sont relou attends je
suis en train de voir ça sur un truc de
chasse comme il y aura quatre mille cinq
cents balles de prix
c'est une saison c'est quoi bah ils sont
relus commença le 3 mai bien aimé y aura
beaucoup d'argent en jeu en fait le
premier moins de 1800 femmes en 2006 en
premier moins de 800 ha ça va gruger de
ouf les arénas maintenant voilà là c'est
moins de 800 on peut voir des prix moins
de 1200 et tout ça ça va être le
festival encore que faut être premium
donc les gens risquent de perdre leur
premium si gruge pas sûr à voir ces
blocs et premium quand même premiers
moins de 8 100es
ouais on va voir c'est pas si sûr que ça
urge autant à voir mais ça devait
commencer le ca devrait commencer en
avril puis ça devait commencer début
avril puis ça devait commencer ce
dimanche puis ça devait commencer le 26
ans sera lé 3
donc bon là c'est la pub en regard le
truc officielle pour rien rater
donc voilà ils ont la pulsion truc
officielle n'a rien à faire
faire que tu perdes quelques parties
ouais ouais faire des prix par catégorie
et l'eau sur les idées de génie
complètement tout vingt neuf ça va être
extraordinaire c'est c'est magique comme
truc non je sais pas après ça peut
marcher c'est les membres premium avoir
quand même j'aurais préféré faire un
délire avec une fois crise yahoo une
fois trois échecs comme on fait un peu à
12h01 x 960 et faire plus de tournois là
il y aura deux mille balles de prix tous
les dimanches
déjà qu'elle a été accusée c'est dur ça
me paraît très ambitieux après ça peut
marcher 1 à faut laisser sa chance au
truc faut laisser sa chance au truc
peut-être des joueurs amateurs vont être
heureux de jouer ils vont jouer le jeu
est possible on va voir les premières
fois ça va être dur puis après peut-être
si ça dépend peut-être silence à sur le
long terme c'est selon s'ils font ça
pendant un an ou deux peut-être à force
et la cadence et je sais pas vrai que je
revois leur pub mais je crois que c'est
du 3 + 0
on va voir si ça arrive après
quand même un peu les anciens arena il y
avait en fait si avec que si c'était
même les 1800 1600 qui devait stream et
ça m'aurait peut-être paru mieux là le
fait que ce soit pas obligé de ce prix
mais pour gagner des prix ça me paraît
quand même très ambitieux jusqu'à la
rigueur de des prix au moins de 800 même
si enfin qu'ils soient obligés de stream
est à mon avis ça ce serait j'aurais été
plus confiant quand même là le fait
qu'il fallait pas forcément stream et ça
me fait un peu peur après on verra de
toute façon épouse 1
épouse on verra ce que ça donne
donc ça va repartir
c'est juste pour le confinement et je
sais pas je le faisais faire combien
j'en aurais aimé voir les stream des 700
noms mais ça aurait permis que ça
c'était pas vraiment pour qui stream
tout vingt neuf c'était pour essayer de
d'avoir moins de jours à contrôler
puisque la quant à tous les membres
premium qui font jouer les 700 les 900
les machins après je pense qu'ils
espèrent sur le fait que comme ils sont
membres diamant ils n'ont pas envie de
perdre leur leur abonnement sur du
cheating on verra bon alors ça rime
contre bortnik comment devient membre
premium assure chess comme des fois tu
as le mode qui met des liens on verra
peut-être f3 et fois 6-1 truc classique
mais bonnie qui m'a déjà battu
quelquefois les quelques faux je veux
contre lui il a fait ce débit m'a
défoncé d'ailleurs en aréna d'ailleurs
en aréna
donc a fait cinq prises prise mais
j'arrive paris va se prendre du cavalier
17 roc dames à 5
j'aurais essayé d'échanger les dames
peut-être plus tôt mais bon j'ai peur de
ce truc là et que les blancs sur
l'impression que je vais faire défoncer
donc
fedama 5 un bien fou ici ce probablement
pendante est rock
b4 en premier quart a lieu deux d'accord
il va leur mettre le cavalier en deux
temps de mettre le fou 1,6 du coup et
qui avait laissé un et je me fais
souvent mater avec ce scène un scénario
là
mécanicien qui avait 17 non mais on
verra toupin pour césar arena soit ça va
bien se passer ce sera cool soit ça se
passera mal et peut-être ils referont le
système de base qui était très bien
d'ailleurs c'était le tournoi le plus
qui font qu'ils avaient c'est le seul
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont décidé d'annuler
mais un maire en fait peut-être voir le
retour de l'ancien format qui était très
très bien si le seul toit de tous les
tournois qui a qui étaient adulés ses
caves extraordinaire mais peut-être
qu'il sera de retour du coup et si ça se
passe bien tant mieux
pour injure et rock avec les normes et
comme je vous dis je joue vraiment mal
ses positions mais j'aurais tellement
envie de faire rentrer matou rage suite
en jeu je me dirais que mon roi est mal
placé mais je vous dis fuis fuis mal
avec les blancs avec les noirs la bonne
soirée matic 6
l'epo s'est fait après thouet après
artemiev c'est pas un jean benoît houde
quoi il est marqué des cinq lycées 3
effectué 17 et je vous dis j'ai aucun
feeling dans ses positions
moi j'en ai fait h4 avec les blancs mais
bon aia qui en fait il veut prendre de 5
oui je suis bête
oui le gagnant 5 vêtements plein les
parties que c'est vraiment un bon joueur
de beat est hyper dangereux
est vraiment dangereux en bis quand tu
t'es fait recruter par de chasse comme à
sur la base de l'audience le qui a t
elle en fait il voulait faire quelque
chose en français ils ont juste pris la
chaîne qui faisait le plus d'audience
tout bêtement intéressant est ce que tu
rentres dans la finale avec la meute 5
on y garde les dames beaucoup plus malin
le dame fouet le roi blanc va être
beaucoup plus faible parce qu'en fait tu
as match 7 hier bref lui tu fais rien
mais qui va faire dame f6 maintenant des
choses comme ça après damas et cissé
adama 8,1
il va falloir être un peu malin encore
est pas si simple dans les six dames à
vis de ses chiens il va falloir
organiser les pièces intelligemment
je chante si tu vois j'ai vu sur youtube
le live est mal partie bon c'est pas
grave c'est je peux pas le changer avec
le mobile et c'est pas forcément c'est
un peu être un peu risqué de changes
autrement inquiète ahmed de foot et 4g
c'est impressionnant ça rhinois et
grosse défense les morts sont mieux ils
ont un pion plus maintenant c'est très
concret est ce que tu arrives à passer
ou pas cru que c'est difficile à jouer
pour les blancs surtout mais c'est juste
une question de concret là je pense
qu'un jeu parfait tient pour les blancs
mais
ah mais il est peut-être pas réalisable
d'ailleurs je pense qu'un ordi peu
pouvait peut-être la tenir maintenant
c'est sûr que c'est fini c'est grosse
défense de sarine une nouvelle fois avec
une seule seconde par coup c'est ultra
dur ce qu'il est en train de faire et il
a fini par se faire mater c'était une
obligation
allez c'est reparti ce qui fait qu'à
three men 1 06 arrivent à les gagner les
portes est très dangereux a vraiment à
effet damas quatre ici c'est quoi
l'intérêt
ok mais qui aurait libé si ça tu cette
variante là avec un temps - et tu penses
que c'est correct donc et ça rentre dans
une variante avec un temps de moins
morningstar fois en faire mais non il a
il a fait une bonne partie il a vraiment
bien géré il justifie cette position là
tu peux la voir avec du porc quasiment
fin à la se fait une raison pour les
noirs mais tu voir la même en ayant joué
dam des trois directs le tam macadam à 3
et là tu fais à 4 t mieux avec les
blancs c'est sûr parce que l'a fait cai
v6 qui a aidé cette île a perdu de temps
aussi et ça et là tu a transposé dans un
truc théorique avantage blanc très clair
roc tourcoing et ça va c'est juste un
vrai plus en plus parce que le pion des
3t content de l'avoir et protège ses 4
des cas de blizzard t4 bizarre c'est la
team a pris cette position mais dire car
le pion détroit assez longtemps si tu
peux parce que il protège le fou et
c'est utile alors quand des cats il est
ciblé mais peut-être c'est bien joué il
a l'air de savoir ce qu'il fait on m'a
parlé de ça il ya dix ans quoi où il ya
15 ans
une année plus tôt donc ça pue ça pue
bien changé depuis le temps
hélas parfois tu as même des idées avec
la tour qui vient à eux cinq et tu peux
te même te laisser prendre par le fou et
pour les deux pions centraux et le roi à
poil
ses compositions saas et les carreaux
cannes avec les double prise ans à la
double prise en dessin que 4 6 et 4
et quand j'ai rencontré je vais dans mon
club donc il sait pas très bien
débrouillé de ce qu'ils avaient bortnik
mais d'un autre côté le truc c'est qu'il
doit que faire annuler
donc quand tu dois que faire nul c'est
tout à fait différent mais ouais il va
faire avec des six en fait être énorme
en maintenant il va faire des 6 et où
sarah il a filé un pion mais il va faire
des six il va tout péter
il devrait gagner deux heures
devrait gagner 2 r il devrait gagner
deux heures bon juste prendre là nul à
la fin amère
il va échanger et peut-être h 3 way
non le truc c'est que le roi noir est
faible et d égalité matérielle via les
flux ont doublé bah ouais enfin c'est
juste un gros avantage après énormément
de bons coups il ya cavale et des 4 kg 3
à l'idée c'est que si prendre la tour tu
peux quand même prendre un f5 ce qui
inclut âge
n'est pas l'abri d'une peau de banane on
aime au gré ça c'est sûr il n'est pas à
l'abri d'une peau de banane c'est une
évidence
merci aristo farc avaient peut-être il
va faire d'un f3 ici qui a quitté dont
français jésus par la censure ta phrase
allez allez correct je semble fatigué
aurait peut-être un peu gras fait 4h30
là que le tournoi a commencé donc c'est
un peu long quoi et c'est intéressant
là on arrive à la fin du tournoi donc
c'est cool là c'est la dame à chiquer g8
va être forcé ce qui menace d'un match 6
dames g7 et qui a été vite dame j'ai
cinq étages et sept matches qui va
arriver
c'est fini par avoir pris 2,01 portique
eux très dangereux quand même j'ai cassé
la même très dangereux
ouais ouais non mais déjà au truc de
bullet il avait été bon je voyais un peu
en dessous en 3 + 1 et sarine m'avait
impressionné mais là c'est gagné
c'est bien joué c'est un cépage pas si
stream d'ailleurs je sais pas si ce
rythme je travaille je vais jeter un
oeil puisque ça stream ou pas
non je crois pas qu'ils stream ou
sinistrés mistry même j'arrive pas à
trouver sa chaîne en tout cas bien joué
mais vraiment bon et c'est vrai c'est
vrai que quand il est en forme et hyper
dangereux je passe si étonnée jetez pas
étonné de le voir dans l'es8 alors je
vais ouvrir après c'est vrai qu'il a
peut-être il a eu un tableau plus facile
aussi faut dire quand même une fois dans
les huit mais impressionnant c'est quand
même vu la force du tournoi pente est
quand même content de lui le maître fide
en quarts et sarine en 2000 mais
messaline c'était quand même un gros
joueur et vous convient en particulier
alors après il fait ses études il a un
peu arrêté un mais devait être bon 2006
2006 50 un gros il faut que je regarde
donc fait voir mensan ça vraiment un
excellent beats heures portiques dans un
bon jour il est lié vraiment dangereux
auquel et 2006 mais has
même et les 26 et 27 23 ans blitz ok
c'est parti pour l'autre il est 27-23 en
anglais c'est un c'est un gros joueur
après ça et quand tu regarde le tableau
il passe bye bye passe comme à travers
de tout le monde pour arriver en finale
c'est voir je vais un peu regardé son
tableau peut-être en jettera un oeil à
son tableau
c'est bientôt la finale balle annoncé la
deuxième demie ça on va enlever du coup
là c'est la deuxième demie après sera la
finale donc la deuxième phase de miel
oppose artemiev avec les blancs attoub
off avec les noirs mais sûrement
artemiev air léger favori quand même d
après jeu très dur à dire qu'il sera
favori de la finale dans les deux cas
dans le sas ou porticcio ouais ça peut
être dangereux
il peut être dangereux quand ici s'il
est chauffé
s'il échoue il peut il peut être très
dangereux ils auraient plus de mal en
trois puis cinq contrats mvl ou un one
aka qui sont peut-être un peu dans le
même style que lui mais en plus fort et
là du coup ça peut faire une une
opposition de style et ça peut tirer à
son avantage on va voir la quille c'est
ça qui est peut-être un fouet pour jouer
sur le clouage me revient à 4 maintenant
que le fou séparé je pense pas qu'il
fasse il en faire en fout des trois en
répétant il fait tourner un revêtement
c'était sûr je fais juste un petit coup
de dé veloppement tu vois ce qui se
passe est peut-être envoyer un c4 un
jour où l'auteur b4
on va voir comment ça évolue ou paour
par l'adam b6 et c 4 bon il va vouloir
arrive pas vraiment fan ne faut pas
prendre pour le moment écartée des
cistes vouloir [ __ ] en c6 d'un
processus force et peut-être même c5 et
c4 fou c'est un d'un côté talent mauvais
fou mais d'un autre côté tu as fait une
belle expansion et à savoir si ça c'est
mieux pour les blancs ou quoi ça doit
jouer au tempo il a fait qui a été hissé
la position qu'on va avoir la france et
6 et 5
ouais ok c 4 pouces et 1 c'était sûr que
ça rentrerait là dedans et ça fait
évaluer qui est mieux parce que 45 et un
coup ici lâche 4,6 et h 50 ils envoient
il va reprendre 2 à 2 truc si tu
reprends 2d ça fait penser à une vieille
partie et plus qui étaient les joueurs
c'est être gligoric avec les noirs mais
où tu te fais pousser au centre toute la
question c'est de savoir si les noirs
peuvent mettre la marche avant ou pas
c'est pas si simple
ouais ok peut-être tu va planter race
partie intéressante
partie intéressante qu'elle envoie le
pion à six fours f6 est quand qu est-ce
qui va s que j'ai cinq du coût kg 5
il veut qu'elle ait lieu car j'imagine
pour jouer sur des programmes français 4
sûrement ça l'idée pour à bab et aux
quatre pour empêcher qu'un maillot 4
justement pouvoir prendre de la tour du
voyage trois accords il vous qui avez
des f4 maintenant pour jouer lyon des
cinq positions et très compliqué mais la
cavalière 4 j'adore ça et dame prend 20
et tu veux jouer dame c3 et les cases
noires ouais c'est bien joué je trouve
et les cases noires alors là pourquoi
ils jouent pas ils regardent qui prend
des cinq intermédiaire elle c'est
couillu parce que tu m'as l'asra dame
français 4 1 je comprends tu peux
hésiter
je félicite et parce que tu vas s'arrête
en d4 il a dû rater ça parce que
maintenant tu te fais raser les deux
furent assez bête d'un provins était le
coup évident et il a voulu être malin et
qui répondait 5 et comme souvent tu
payes la maline est ce parce que tu
perds tes deux pions alors que tu
pourrais avoir encore en vie après un
première dame ces trois espions des cinq
façons ils étaient bloqués ouais c'est
dommage pour artemiev partie génial et
au moment où il a voulu faire le coup
encore un peu plus fort il a faibli mais
rien n'est fait il ya quand même le roi
qui est très faible et des cavaliers m6
qui rôdent bam f3 j'aime bien surprise
en 3 ça va tout échanger et d'ahmed de à
la fin et ça doit aller roanne ce qui me
sens levée de ce truc là là d'amoureux
de hockey vont peut-être partir vers à 2
voilà c'est ça ça se joue à rien les
mecs damas deux peut-être donc m6 en
premier risque 1,8 en l'air aussi ça
échange quelques îles et angers 4 mais
il ya des dames à 2 qui rôde et la prise
prisé tour 17 caisses est beaucoup plus
agréable à jouer pour les blancs est ce
que c'est gagné ou pas je sais pas mais
tour g77 ça arrive
cavalli g4 c'était l'idée et toura je
suis à huit qui avaient des problèmes si
seul coup cinéma h 7 h 8 et maintenant
tête tour à 8 es tu veux tout raciste
bien joué et 3g 6h c'est toi y'a juste
pour approche et 3 m6 est sur moi
j'essaie tout problème 6 ouais c'est
laisser là c'est mérité quand même pour
artemiev parce que c'est lui qui a créé
le jeu il a été très très bon art et
bien flat dessus
elle part si ouais franchement excellent
deux parties franchement excellentissime
partie est là il faudrait de trucs avec
d'amd de et va jouer avec des trois fous
les deux pays ces trois grands rock
c'est la partie car la scène post à sec
qui avait donné une belle partie et une
belle victoire à karl scène on trouvera
toutes à sec
non il a envoyé un mot du coup ils
jouent différemment leur avance à jouer
avec mes trois fours et 2 je sais que
l'égalité avait été trouvé sa perle à 10
heures pour rien que faire d'un mètre
quatre vingt matches 4 et une attaque à
l'ancienne avec x 6 kg 5
ouais la d25 ou blizzard ne le joue pas
à sochaux
l'idée c'est que soit tu peux lever 3
four b2 et alarme est déjà revenue en d2
fait quand ils viennent des quatre soit
tu veut la ramener tranquillement vers
h4 et du coup là aussi ça s'explique
ok ça pénible à jouer
pour aller noir
donc
celui-ci soit tu es éliminé les fous de
cases noires est attaqué sur les droits
souvent des pions sont pas fixés quand
tu sais où attaquer enfin après tu sais
pas par rapport à la structure de pions
tu le sais par rapport à la structure de
pions voilà comment il va continuer ta
vraie situant la situation c'est ce truc
dont on parlait juste avant mais quand
tu dois faire un nul
parfois ça te fait tilter de te faire
attaquer comme ça ça te met sous
pression et tu peux te mettre à mal
jouer aussi et je trouve que jusqu'à
maintenant dans cette compétition les
joueurs gèrent très bien le fait de
devoir jouer juste pour la nuit je les
trouve vraiment se pose pas de questions
après ça vexe et du blitz mais il se
pose pas de question
donc non mais encore il n'y a pas eu
toute faiblesse attaqué le roi n'est pas
idiot 1 kg 5 semble être un coup à très
clairement mais il va faire cavalier
avis il va revenir
ça s'est fait avec kadhafi si ces
affaires pied prend une scission 3,6 et
c'est pas si sûr que ça que ce soit
simple de contient avec les blancs un
féret feu
michael me haïk et blanc il a quand même
tout le jeu hein
25e et 5 tempo d'amasser 3 h un
mais c'est très difficile 3 3 twh
croirait pas aussi bien sûr très
dangereux sur fion kroeff katia même
carey price 4 maintenant
toif 3g en programmant une cavale et
prend sti détour f cell c comment
quantifier car réussi six as plus
fourchette carew 5 est aussi sévère
ramener le ranger 8
sa seule chance avec les noirs c'est que
le fou si le foot et les portes en b3 ce
serait mort mais y'a pas poussé quatre
et il n'y a pas le cul en c3 donc le fou
et l'on a ramené signal s'est fait
éliminer rai tg3 d'amd cette 4e 4
sûrement un spoiler alert l'ordi donne
un avantage de noir maintenant je suis
hyper étonné par la qualité de la
défense d'arte et nief va vraiment très
bien joué il a réussi à vis et le pion
et les blancs devais avoir quelque chose
pour faire et là maintenant sur un come
down price is equal fric et 4 dames h4
et g5 d'un mach 5 km2 rage inquiets
prend des airs il ya jamais d'attaquants
fait y'a jamais rien dire il a fait
c'est la partie d'ailleurs en restait
avant que la plus humaine tu avais envie
de continuer ça et c'est pas pour rien
qu'il a loué sa et puis on prend f4 et
il va faire payer pour un f3 en fait et
c'est fini artemiev de zaire énorme
artemiev un impressionnant
impressionnant artemiev énorme partie
très bien joué et a déjà été fait forte
impression contre nez peau mais c'est
pas pour rien qu'il est 3002 sur le site
hein c'est pas pour rien que les trois
mineurs j'avais une petite pub je vais
remettre leur live sur mon téléphone
mais ça va être une finale sympa alors
vas voir je vais aller voir au live
earth et meichtry peut-être sûrement pas
alors ça reprend sa reprendre en trois
minutes
la finale est chaude et qualitative
donc
dans le languedoc
donc là ça a joué pour 5000 balle quand
même enfin le deuxième prend 1500
ça va envoyer bon à voir
donc c'est 3000 le deuxième j'ai vu dans
la vitesse bon moi je vais quand même
artemiev favori 1 s'il réussit à
contenir le le côté un peu tactique
arnaque de bortnik il va lui coller a
pris ce nom mais ils favoris comme il
est quand même bien bien favori mais ok
2 parties tout peut arriver
deux parties tout peut arriver
donc je suis bien sur leurs écrans en
fait je voulais voir ce n'est pas une
règle finale spéciale pour la finale
mais apparemment non
tout cas beau tournoi à la phase finale
était vraiment cool la phase finale
était vraiment cool pas tous les mecs de
l'ap seconde partie tableau de bâtard
elles étaient plus forts que ceux de la
partie du hockey
je suis d'accord avec toi parce que
ouais il avait le maître fide bortnik
était même pas favori du truc mais de
l'autre côté c'était sarid contre parra
mais c'est vrai qu'en batave est née
peau d'où box vide l'air artemiev ouais
c'était la partie basse était beaucoup
plus forte
je suis 100% d'accord
voyez les deux beaux matches c'était
assez sympa borloo veut il mène que ces
deux retours mais doherty à la partie du
bas avec eux des russes ouais c'était
une grosse grosse partie de tableau et
c'est pour ça que en plus il a gagné les
deux matches 2-0 artémias fini la
mi-2011 et pau et 2,0 à double face et
quand même c'est quand même fort ça
commence quand 16 ans et recommencer
maintenant j'ai mangé quoi je mange
après en fait qu'al col j'ai pas le
temps de manger du coup je vais manger
après ça va être une belle finale c'est
sûr ça va envoyer du pâté
donc
c'est qu'ils m'ont favoris comme j'ai
dit si berne elephant donc artemiev
artemiev pour moi gros favoris mais
possibilité de possibilités surprise
donc un matelas en fait possibilité
surprise alors il est khan à 4 mètres ça
ici
même grosses possibilités surprise si un
ils en font de nancy 1 normalement si un
partout où ils vont
si un parti ira armageddon a normalement
ça va resté pareil alors il ya peut-être
match pour la troisième place pardon
match pour la 3e place avant ça rime
contre doug of excusez moi je savais pas
qu'il y avait deux matches d'un match
pour la troisième place sa lutte au
tabac bon match pour la troisième place
avec l'enjeu de faire un truc sympa avec
l'enjeu de faire un truc sympa et joua
prénom enfin fraîche et or vient après
je vais dormir et à peine fait lmv elle
s'est fait éliminer très très tôt dans
la compétition
je crois qu'après la quatrième ronde il
a déjà plus aucune chance de gagner
mais voilà il a peut-être pas non plus
pris la compétition très au sérieux sa
mission du golfe
donc
chez d4 qu'il prend des quatre bogeys ça
va être un avantage blanc petit avec le
pion des simples qu en tout cas plus
agréable à jouer maintenant il ya un peu
de jeu pour les noirs au siècle de
l'attak
moi je prendrais les blancs parce que je
préfère les petits avantages long terme
mais bon ça doit sensiblement a les
seins d'amy tam e7 qui a aidé deux vrais
tu développes après à kiev 3 après les
noix ont quand même du jeu
c'est à deux sur un jeu seraient connus
que dans plusieurs sphères ouais je suis
pas un fan inconditionnel de ces finales
pour la troisième place mais je peux
comprendre c'est quand même enfin
j'allais quand même beaucoup d'argent en
jeu tu vas pour un toit de cinq six
heures il ya dix mille dollars en jeu je
peux comprendre qu'un match pour la
troisième place après dans les
compétitions individuelles comme ça je
suis pas fan fan mais ma foi je peux
comprendre les envies des organisateurs
d'avoir un match de plus
c'est comme une belle affiche sarine
compte du boeuf
il ya le foot j'aimerais moi aussi où il
ya le foot ça tourne un peu c'est cool
après dans les compètes individuels
comme ça que ça dure quand même un long
moment le même jour ça fait un peu long
mais je peux comprendre en battant insee
cambrai et je trouve que la vitrine cup
c'était plus cool en fait c'est juste
que le format était meilleure c'est pas
une question de palpitant c'est jusque
il y avait beaucoup d'action sur très
peu de temps c'était fait pour être
dynamique et pour faire de l'ipod et que
quatre jours à vitry cabuay c'était fait
pour en fait t'es servi joueurs
s'arrêter sur deux week-ends et ça
aurait fait un peu ces mêmes formats
avec deux matchs deux matchs deux matchs
deux matches comme ça ça ça te fait de
l'action ça fait six parties
s'enchaînent vite passé six parties par
cette max ça enchaîne vie qui est une
petite pause de cinq minutes ça discute
interview après match et ça enchaîne
n'ai pas de petite finale donc c'est un
truc qui était pensé pour ce prix mais
pour faire de l'ipad fait et pas pour
autre chose
parce que c'est possible d'organiser un
événement financier chinois tu sais j'ai
un projet comme ça mais pour le moment
j'essaye de faire avec caisse comme
j'aurais demandé un budget on verra et
j'espère que c'est moi qui ferai le qui
ferait de formant au moins il y aura de
nouveau le format de 7 et mac seront pas
trop longs etc
après si le truc est pas entre les mains
ça va refaire un format speech sk mise
adore et les matchs vont durer quatre
heures ce sera relou passera plus l'idée
que que je m'en faisais ouais j'ai déjà
conseillé le format 7 et tout en disant
que c'était mieux mais ça va forcément
été écoutés comme tu le vois mais moi je
trouve que c'est mille fois mieux mais
bon après chacun son point de vue un
prêt chacun son point de vue j'ai pas la
science infuse leur speech est ça marche
bien c'est que c'est ça dépend des
matches à des matchs vous sait très bien
qu'on c'est long comme ça le format 7 je
crois que c'est quelque chose que nous
on préfère en europe et que il a moins
aux états unis voient les trois plus un
sur internet c'est plus court je suis
d'accord mais l'autriche après nous on
voulait vous voulez pas que les joueurs
surtout maxime est ou a besoin de faire
des grosses parties qu'ils puissent flac
silence